gráfica todos los posibles valores para
h en la recta numérica que cumplan la
siguiente desigualdad y esta siguiente
desigualdad tiene una cierta
peculiaridad que tiene valor absoluto
tenemos el valor absoluto de h menos 19
medios esto tiene que ser menor que
menos 12 y cómo resolvemos este tipo de
desigualdades pues lo primero que hay
que hacer o lo mejor que se me ocurre es
despejar lo más que se pueda el valor
absoluto de h lo que tiene que ver con
el valor absoluto en este caso de h de
un lado de esta desigualdad y de hecho
creo que sería mucho más fácil dejarlo
del lado izquierdo y por lo tanto lo que
voy a hacer primero es sumar 19 enteros
un medio de ambos lados de esta
desigualdad de aquí y del lado derecho
de la desigualdad también voy a sumar 19
enteros un medio y ojo fíjate como la
desigualdad se conserva y entonces estos
dos se van y me queda decirle
sencillamente del lado izquierdo de esta
desigualdad el valor absoluto de h
mientras que del lado derecho me queda
menos 12 más 19 enteros un medio esto es
7 enteros un medio menos 12 más 19
siete enteros un medio del lado derecho
de esta desigualdad y por lo tanto tengo
que el valor absoluto de h es menor que
siete enteros un medio lo padre del
asuntos que ya tenemos despejado el
valor absoluto de h de un lado de esta
desigualdad sin embargo ahora cómo
podemos resolver esta desigualdad y
quiero que recuerdes que el valor
absoluto también representa una cierta
distancia a qué distancia estamos o qué
tan lejos estamos del cero es decir aquí
estamos diciendo que me quiero tomar
todas las áreas que cumplan que su valor
absoluto sea menor que siete enteros un
medio o dicho de otra manera que la
distancia de cualquier h de estas h que
van a ser una solución al cero sea menor
que siete enteros un medio y bueno de
una manera rápida lo que primero que nos
podemos dar cuenta es que cualquier
número que sea menor que siete enteros
un medio y que además sea positivo pues
cumple esto por ejemplo si yo me tomo
tres la distancia del 3 al 0 es menor
que 7 enteros un medio por lo tanto
podemos decir que h tiene que ser menor
que 7 enteros un medio
y hay que tener cuidado no son todos las
haches que sean menores que siete
enteros un medio es decir que tenemos
que parar en un cierto punto y en qué
punto tenemos que parar pues bueno h a
su vez tiene que ser mayor que menos
siete enteros un medio date cuenta que
cualquier número que esté entre menos
siete enteros un medio y el cero cuando
yo me tomo su valor absoluto es mucho
más chico que siete enteros un medio por
lo tanto ya tengo que menos siete
enteros un medio o tiene que ser menor
que h y a su vez tiene que ser menor que
siete enteros un medio así que ahora sí
podemos ponerlo en nuestra recta
numérica si por aquí tengo el 7 y por
aquí tengo al 8 y de este lado por aquí
tengo al menos 7 y por acá tengo el
menos 8 entonces todas las haches que
son solución y que cumplen esta
desigualdad con valor absoluto son
aquellas que son más grandes que 7
enteros un medio y a su vez son más
pequeñas que 7 enteros un medio y date
cuenta que es un intervalo abierto
porque nuestra desigualdad es estricta y
por aquí tenemos al menos siete enteros
un medio y yo quiero todas las haches
que estén entre estos dos puntos va a
cumplir mi desigualdad con valor
absoluto así que déjame dibujar 2
numérica cualquier cantidad que esté en
este intervalo claramente su distancia
al 0 es menor que 7 enteros un medio